president biden woke up in the white  house for the first time this morning  spending his first full day in office  laser focused on the cobit pandemic  signing a full 10 executive orders this  is a wartime undertaking  today i'm signing executive action to  use the defense production act  and all other available authorities to  direct all federal agencies  and private industry to accelerate the  making of everything is needs to protect  test vaccinate and take care of our  people  the president and vice president kamala  harris also met with dr  anthony fauci and his coronavirus team  now a 200-page national covet strategy  book was released today some of the  goals listed  are restoring trust in the american  people emergency relief and the whole  book is available  over on 8 news down dot com cbs evening  news will have much more  on president biden's strategy at 5 30.